in Europa
fast 80 Jahren nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg versucht Russland mit Gewalt
mit Panzern und Raketen die Grenzen auf
dem Kontinent zu verschieben und droht
dabei mit dem Einsatz seiner Atomwaffen
wer versucht uns aufzuhalten
sollte wissen dass die Antworten
Russlands sofort erfolgen und zu nie
gesehenen Konsequenzen führen werden
im russischen Staatsfernsehen wird die
atomare Vernichtung ganzer Länder
angedroht
die britische Insel ist so klein dass
eine einzige Atomrakete reicht um sie
für immer zu versenken alles wurde
bereits berechnet die Drohungen
überschreiten alle roten Linien die
selbst im Kalten Krieg respektiert
wurden gesehen tatsächlich in dem
aktuellen Krieg eine
zutiefst beunruhigende Verschiebung im
Verständnis von nuklearer Abschreckung
das Gleichgewicht des Schreckens gerät
ins Wanken Russland missbraucht das
Prinzip der Abschreckung für seine
eigenen Zwecke aus Russland jetzt macht
ist ich führe unter dem Schutz meiner
Atomwaffen einen eroberungs-
wie sicher können wir sein dass die
gegenseitige Abschreckung noch
funktioniert dort
[Musik]
die Metropole Odessa die Millionenstadt
am Schwarzen Meer gilt laut Experten als
ein mögliches Ziel für einen russischen
Atom Angriff die Widerstandskraft der
ukrainischen Stadt für Putin eine
Provokation ihre Zerstörung wäre ein
Schlag gegen die Ukraine als Nation ihre
Menschen und ihre Kultur
vom Meer aus schießt die russische
Flotte Raketen auf die Stadt und das
ganze Land die Raketen könnten auch
jederzeit mit atomaren Sprengköpfen
bestückt werden
Polina sinowits ist
nuklearwaffenexpertin aus Odessa
alle Raketen die gegen die Ukraine
eingesetzt werden können atomsprenköpfe
tragen das ist die schlechte Nachricht
die meisten Experten neigen zu der
Annahme dass wenn Atomwaffen eingesetzt
werden die Ukraine das erste Ziel sein
wird
[Musik]
die Bevölkerung und deshalbs leidet seit
Monaten unter dem Krieg georg ist
Besitzer eines Lebensmittelladens in der
Innenstadt seitdem die Russen die
Stromleitungen und Kraftwerke zerstört
haben können die meisten Menschen zu
Hause nicht mehr selber kochen gewogs
Lösung erstellt jetzt Fertiggerichte her
so viele wie möglich solange Strom da
ist mal reicht die Zeit nur für ein paar
Essen manchmal werden es dutzende
egal wie viele es werden in seinem Laden
sind sie schnell ausverkauft das Angebot
reicht längst nicht für alle
[Musik]
zu all den Belastungen kommt noch bei
vielen die Angst vor einem möglichen
russischen Atomangriff dazu
jeder normale Mensch denke ich auch
darüber nach und mache mir Sorgen meine
Familie lebt in Odessa und es ist klar
dass dies eine sehr große Bedrohung für
uns alle und für die ganze Ukraine ist
aber ich habe die große Hoffnung dass
die Welt Europa und Amerika alles tun
werden um eine nuklearen Angriff auf die
Ukraine zu verhindern denn das wäre eine
Katastrophe von globalem Ausmaß
[Musik]
für die die sich gewogs fertig ist nicht
leisten können gibt es in Odessa mehrere
Tafeln
alexander gorenjuk ist
Parlamentsabgeordneter und organisiert
seit Monaten die Lebensmittelhilfen für
die Bevölkerung
[Musik]
was einen möglichen Angriff anbelangt so
nehme ich es ernst wenn es plötzlich
eine Atombombe von russischer Seite gibt
wir lesen Informationen im Internet bei
der Arbeit sprechen wir mit Kollegen
unsere Vorgesetzten beraten uns auch ein
wenig welche Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
anzuwenden sind was zu tun ist wenn so
etwas plötzlich passiert
Alexander gorenjuk kümmert sich auch um
den Zivilschutz in der Stadt
ganz Odessa ist seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg von Katakomben durchzogen
Alexander führt uns in den größten
Bunker Odessas und ist der Verzweiflung
nahe
8000 Menschen sollten hier Platz finden
doch nach mehreren schweren Explosionen
an der Oberfläche brachen
Versorgungsleitungen und der Bunker
wurde überschwemmt
jetzt sind alle Räume kalt und feucht
und es schimmelt überall
vor etwa sieben Monaten gab es hier eine
Generalreinigung und es gab Wasser und
alles aber leider ist etwas passiert die
Stadtverwaltung hat darauf noch nicht
reagiert wir werden wohl noch warten
müssen auf jeden Fall können die
Menschen hier erstmal Schutz finden wenn
sie wieder mit Raketen
unterschiedlichster Größe beschossen
werden
doch gegen einen Atom Angriff würde auch
das nicht helfen dem wären die Menschen
schutzlos ausgeliefert Alexander
gorenjux einzige Hoffnung ist das Putin
nicht zur Bombe greift
seit den russischen atomdrohungen ist
die Welt eine andere in Paris gibt es
mehrere Forschungsinstitute die sich mit
dem Thema nukleare Abschreckung
beschäftigen das ist das Fachgebiet von
Polina sinowits sie arbeitet derzeit als
Gast an der renommierten französischen
Stiftung für strategische Forschung dort
untersucht sie welchen militärischen
Sinn der Einsatz von taktischen
Atomwaffen in der Ukraine haben könnte
als taktische Atomwaffen bezeichnet man
Waffen mit relativ geringer Sprengkraft
und Reichweite
eine Option wäre es einen Gegenangriff
der ukrainischen Streitkräfte zu
verhindern mit einem taktischen Atom
Sprengkopf doch militärisch ist das
keine Lösung denn um einen Angriff
wirklich zu stoppen müssten Atomwaffen
auf der gesamten Frontlinie eingesetzt
werden das ist ein riesiges Gebiet eine
riesige Grenze zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine und dementsprechend würde es
etwa 100 Atomschläge brauchen
aus militärischer Sicht mache der
Einsatz von taktischen Atomwaffen keinen
Sinn sagt sie Polina sinowitsch hat
analysiert was Putin mit seinem
Drohungen erreichen möchte
[Musik]
Russland keine nukleare Abschreckung
hätte wäre es sehr wahrscheinlich das
NATO Soldaten in der Ukraine kämpfen
würden
russische truppenbombardieren und die
Ukraine direkt militärisch unterstützen
Abschreckung hat als Hauptzweck die
nahto davon abzuhalten direkt in den
Konflikt einzugreifen
einer der regelmäßig mit atomangriffen
auf die Ukraine aber auch auf London
oder Berlin droht ist der ehemalige
russische Präsident Dimitri Medvedev in
einem Post of telegram schreibt ihr im
Herbst 2022
russland hat das Recht im Bedarfsfall
Atomwaffen einzusetzen
und immer wieder sorry heute ist mit
weddiew stellvertretender Vorsitzender
des russischen Sicherheitsrates seit
Tagen sind wir mit seinem Sprecher in
Kontakt nun sind wir zu einem
Online-Interview mit ihm verabredet wir
wollen ihn fragen warum er im Namen
Russlands dem Westen mit Atomkrieg droht
doch zum vereinbarten Zeitpunkt ist er
für uns nicht mehr erreichbar
[Musik]
wir schicken die Fragen schriftlich
auch darauf erhalten wir keine Antwort
es gelingt uns den russischen Ex-General
Viktor yessin zu interviewen er sitzt in
Moskau und gilt als immer noch gut
informiert über den aktuellen Zustand
der russischen atomstreitkräfte als
General war er viele Jahre für die
strategischen atomarsenale Russlands
zuständig
89 Prozent der russischen Kernwaffen
sind auf dem modernsten Stand der
Technik
diese Zahl wurde letzten Dezember auf
dem Kollegium des
Verteidigungsministeriums verkündet da
verrate ich ihn also kein Geheimnis und
das wird auch durch Raketenstarts bei
militärischen Übungen bestätigt alle
Staats waren erfolgreich ich kann Ihnen
sagen dass die russischen nukleare
Streitkräfte einsatzbereit sind
mehr für generalier Sinn hat sich nach
Kriegsbeginn die Gefahr des Einsatzes
von Atomwaffen erheblich erhöht da aus
russischer Sicht die NATO längst am
Krieg beteiligt sei und es so zu einer
direkten Konfrontation kommen können
es ist diese Bedrohung durch eine
direkte Konfrontation die die Gefahr des
Einsatzes von Atomwaffen in die Höhe
treibt denn wenn es zu einer solchen
direkten Konfrontation käme so fürchte
ich würde sie sich nicht auf
konventionelle Streitkräfte beschränken
es würde zu einer atomaren Eskalation
kommen
für den russischen Ex-General wächst die
Gefahr eines Zusammenstoßes mit der NATO
im ukrainekrieg von Tag zu Tag und damit
auch das Risiko einer atomaren
Konfrontation erstmals seit dem Ende des
Kalten Krieges so sagt er müsse sich nun
erweisen ob die nukleare Abschreckung
noch funktioniert
[Musik]
Claudia major berät die Bundesregierung
in Sicherheitsfragen bei der Stiftung
für Wissenschaft und Politik ist sie
forschungsleiterin für
Sicherheitspolitik Putins Drohungen mit
dem Atomkrieg empfindet sie als überaus
besorgniserregend
wir sehen tatsächlich in dem aktuellen
Krieg eine
zutiefst beunruhigende Verschiebung im
Verständnis von nuklearer Abschreckung
das traditionelle Verständnis von
nuklearer Abschreckung ist wie ein
Status Quo zu beschützen die eigene
Ordnung zu beschützen das eigene
Territorium zu beschützen und dazu
werden Nuklearwaffen als Abschreckung
eingesetzt was Russland jetzt macht ist
ich führe unter dem Schutz meiner
Atomwaffen einen eroberungs-art
durchsetzt wenn man damit und wenn
Russland damit ungeschoren durchkommt
wenn das Schule macht dass ein Sieg
unter dem nuklearsche machbar ist dann
hat das
fundamentale Auswirkungen auf die
internationale Ordnung
das Problem Putins Kalkül geht auf er
droht mit Atomwaffen verschärft den
Krieg in der Ukraine und der Westen hält
sich bis auf Waffenlieferungen raus doch
die dauernden Drohungen bergen eine
enorme Gefahr was wäre wenn Putin
tatsächlich den Einsatz einer Atombombe
anordnen würde wie könnte der Westen wie
müsste die NATO reagieren
[Musik]
wir fliegen in die Vereinigten Staaten
die Atommacht USA ist die Führungsmacht
der NATO und garantiert den
militärischen Schutz Europas Präsident
beiden versucht seit Beginn der
russischen Drohungen Putin eine
möglichst eindeutige Botschaft zu senden
was würden Sie ihm sagen wenn er
beabsichtigt chemische oder taktische
nukleare Waffen einzusetzen
Hans kristenson ist Direktor des nuklear
Information projects er beobachtet seit
Jahrzehnten die militärischen
Kapazitäten beider Seiten und weiß wie
die NATO auf einen russischen
Atomangriff reagieren würde falls
Russland Atomwaffen in der Ukraine
einsetzen sollte würde die NATO mit
einer militärischen einer direkten
konventionellen Antwort reagieren und es
besteht kein Zweifel daran dass sobald
die NATO beginnt mit konventionellen
Waffen einzugreifen die russischen
Streitkräfte verlieren werden sie können
nicht gewinnen und so würden die Russen
erneut nuklear zu schlagen es sei denn
sie kapitulieren einfach was ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich ist diese Eskalation
kann sehr sehr schnell außer Kontrolle
geraten
wenn es zu einer direkten Konfrontation
zwischen NATO und Russland käme stünde
beiden Seiten eine schier unglaubliche
Vernichtungskraft zur Verfügung allein
Russland besitzt 4.500 Sprengköpfe sie
können aus Raketen sie los von oder
mobilen Abschussrampen verschossen
werden aber auch von Bombern oder sogar
der Artillerie dabei setzt Russland
schon immer auf Masse und auf Größe
bereits 1961 erreichte die Zar Bombe die
3800-fache Stärke der Hiroshima-Bombe
die Druckwelle umrundete die Erde
dreimal und ließ noch in 1000 km
Entfernung Fensterscheiben bersten
auch das Arsenal der Vereinigten Staaten
ist gigantisch
3700 Sprengköpfe auf Teil modernster
Waffensysteme wie Atom U-Boote über
schallbomber und Raketensilos
das Gefährliche daran beide Lager können
auch dann noch zurückschlagen wenn ihre
Länder längst vollständig zerstört sind
der sogenannte Zweitschlag
beide Seiten treiben einen enormen
Aufwand um die Arsenale des jeweils
anderen im Blick zu haben das gilt
gerade für kleinere bewegliche Systeme
the Russian die russischen taktischen
Nuklearwaffen befinden sich alle in
einem zentralen Lager zumindest soweit
wir wissen
wenn Sie taktische Atomwaffen einsetzen
wollten müssten sie die Sprengköpfe
zunächst aus dem zentralen Lager zu den
Einheiten in dem Gebiet bringen von dem
aus sie abgefeuert werden sollen
und das würde einige Tage dauern und
wäre möglicherweise nachweisbar aber es
gibt natürlich keine Gewissheit
niemand nicht einmal die USA können
sicher vorhersagen ob und wann ein
russischer Atomangriff bevorstehen würde
sagen uns Experten und natürlich wissen
niemand genau ob Putin sich durch die
Warnungen der USA wirklich von einem
Atomangriff auf die Ukraine abhalten
ließe
[Musik]
what Wilson ist Historiker und
beschäftigt sich seit Jahrzehnten mit
der Frage ob das was man Abschreckung
nennt tatsächlich funktioniert
Abschreckung ist eine Drohung um etwas
zu verhindern
wenn Sie also diesen Keks stehlen
schicke ich sie ohne Abendessen ins Bett
oder wenn sie auf der anderen Seite des
Flusses einmarschieren werden meine
Truppen sie angreifen oder wenn sie mein
Land mit Atomwaffen angreifen werde ich
sie ebenfalls mit Atomwaffen angreifen
das Problem mit Drogen ist dass sie
nicht physisch sind sie wirken im Kopf
ihres Gegners was sie weniger
zuverlässig macht als andere
verteidigungsmethoden
die Zukunft der Menschheit hängt an der
Frage ob die nukleare Abschreckung
funktioniert zu groß sind die Arsenale
der Zerstörung doch die Zeiten haben
sich geändert inzwischen seien die
Gegner nicht mehr berechenbar
wir wissen nicht wo die roten Linien bei
Atomwaffen verlaufen und niemand weiß
das selbst die Verantwortlichen wissen
es nicht an einem Tag wachen sie auf und
sind zuversichtlich und glücklich und
sie sind sicher dass alles gut gehen
wird am nächsten Tag wachen sie auf sind
mürrisch und traurig und Denken zum
Teufel damit lass uns die Waffen
abfeuern es gibt keine wissenschaftliche
Methode zu berechnen ob ich es wirklich
ernst meine oder nicht die nukleare
Abschreckung hat also in den letzten 70
Jahren einigermaßen funktioniert und sie
könnte noch eine Weile funktionieren
aber im Grunde ist es ein Glücksspiel
jeden Tag
nukleare Abschreckung ein Glücksspiel
und das bei der derzeit ohnehin
angespannten Lage
[Musik]
an der östlichen Außengrenze der NATO
liegt Litauen hier besteht laut Experten
die größte Gefahr einer direkten
Konfrontation zwischen der Nato und
russischen Soldaten die Nato hat ihre
militärische Präsenz massiv erhöht und
Litauen stellt freiwilligen Verbände auf
Litauen grenzt sowohl an Weißrussland
als auch an die russische Exklave
Kaliningrad
[Musik]
in der Hauptstadt Vilnius treffen wir
Andreus kubilus er ist ehemaliger
Premierminister und heute Russland
Beauftragte des EU-Parlaments er will
uns zeigen wie Putin und sein
weißrussischer Verbündeter Lukaschenko
seit etwa einem Jahr grenzt
Zwischenfälle verursachen er sieht darin
eine Städte Provokation und
Machtdemonstration des russischen
Präsidenten
mit cubelius können wir ein
Hauptquartier der Grenztruppen in der
Nähe der Hauptstadt besuchen
unser Grenzabschnitt hier überwacht etwa
die 30 km Grenze zu Weißrussland
[Musik]
gemeinsam mit dem Kommandeur machen wir
uns auf den Weg zur Grenze
haben sie Putin jemals persönlich
getroffen
ich habe ihn einmal getroffen als er die
Rolle des Premierministers gespielt hat
mein Eindruck war dass er sofort spürt
wenn du nicht so stark bist dann springt
er dich an wie ein Straßenschläger aus
Leningrad
früher war die Grenze zu Weißrussland
unbefestigt doch mit der zunehmenden
aggressiveren Politik Russlands
beschloss Litauen das zu ändern aus
gutem Grund seit letztem Jahr lässt
Putin überweis Russland Flüchtlinge aus
dem Irak und Syrien nach Litauen
Schleusen immer wieder wird der Zaun
durchgeschnitten
wenn sie mal schauen wollen das ist
unsere grenzüberwachungsanlage
[Musik]
in der Überwachungszentrale zeigen sie
uns genau diese Stelle am Zaun in einer
Aufnahme aus dem Sommer dutzende
Flüchtlinge fliehen durch den vorher von
den weißrusssen durchgeschnittenen Zaun
an einer anderen Stelle treiben
bewaffnete weißrussische Soldaten
Flüchtlinge über die Grenze und stehen
unvermittelt Grenzsoldaten des
nato-staates Litauen gegenüber
tausende Flüchtlinge wurden so von
Russland in die EU geschleust Litauen
war darauf nicht vorbereitet das sei ein
Krieg ohne Waffen sagt uns Andreas
kubelius das Ziel die Stabilisierung des
Gegners das sei eine Spezialität des Ex
KGB Agenten Putin
das ist eine Art von hybrider
Kriegsführung und Moskau ist auf jeden
Fall daran beteiligt denn die
geflüchteten fliegen nach Moskau und
nehmen den Zug von Moskau nach Minsk und
von Minsk kommen sie an die litauische
Grenze
Hybride Kriegsführung
muss zurück nach Vilnius am Tag zuvor
ist es ihm gelungen Russland vom
EU-Parlament als Terrorstaat einstufen
zu lassen für ihn ein Meilenstein zu dem
er nun Interviews geben muss
auch die ehemalige
Verteidigungsministerin Rasa
juknewiczienne unterstützt die
Einstufung Russlands als Terrorstaat
während ihrer Amtszeit von 2008 bis 2012
registrierte sie eine beispiellose
Aufrüstung der russischen Streitkräfte
die Region Kaliningrad wurde zu einer
modernen Festung ausgebaut
einschließlich Atomwaffen wie S400 und
es kann der Raketen und U-Boote die
Russen übten den Anschluss von
Kaliningrad an Weißrussland mit den
russischen Streitkräften vor Ort dass er
aus wie ein Film eine theoretische
Fähigkeit aber jetzt sehen wir es war
keine theoretische Übung jetzt verstehen
wir dass sie das getan haben um sich
darauf vorzubereiten was Sie jetzt tun
die ehemalige Verteidigungsministerin
fürchtet die Manöver Russlands könnten
Kriegsvorbereitungen gegen die NATO sein
die russischen Truppen übten die
Eroberung der sogenannten sowki-lücke
das ist eine nur 65 Kilometer lange
Grenzregion zwischen den NATO-Staaten
Litauen und Polen sie trennt das
russische Kaliningrad von Weißrussland
die sowjillücke gilt als einer der
verwundbarsten Punkte der NATO in der
Region hier könnte Russland die
baltischen Staaten vom Rest der NATO
abschneiden
der Einsatz taktische Atomwaffen wäre
dabei eine Möglichkeit
[Musik]
die Sicherheitsexpertin Claudia major
erklärt uns wie die NATO auf einen
Angriff reagieren würde das ist klar
geregelt in Artikel 5
Artikel 5 ist das Herzstück vom
Washingtoner Vertrag also von dem NATO
Gründungsvertrag und Artikel 5 ich nenne
es immer gerne die Lebensversicherung
ist die beistandsklausel darin
verpflichten sich die Staaten wenn einer
angegriffen wird dass alle anderen
beistehen werden das heißt ein atomarer
Angriff auf eine nato-staat wie Litauen
oder auch Polen würde eine militärische
Reaktion hervorrufen dazu könnten auch
in Westeuropa stationierte Atombomben
eingesetzt werden
Frankreich besitzt 300 Großbritannien
225 dazu kommen etwa 100 amerikanische
Atombomben die quer über Europa verteilt
in Belgien Italien und den Niederlanden
lagern in Deutschland sind es um die 20
in Rheinland-Pfalz in dem kleinen Ort
Büchel liegen die amerikanischen
Atombomben zum einsatzbereit am Eingang
des fliegerhauses steht auch ein
ausgemusterter deutscher Tornado mit den
neueren Typen sollen die Atombomben ins
Ziel gebracht werden im Rahmen der
sogenannten nuklearen Teilhabe
wenn Sie 100 Atomwaffen in Europa haben
und vielleicht vier oder fünf Dutzend
Jets die sie abwerfen können dann hat
das einen gewissen abschreckungswert der
residents value somewhere
doch genau das ist es was Inga Blum
wirklich Sorgen macht
wir treffen die Kinderärztin und
Friedensaktivistin am Eingang zur
Kaserne wie so viele hat sie Angst vor
einem Atomkrieg
sie reagiert auf die gestiegene
Kriegsgefahr mit einem Appell es geht
jetzt darum dass ganz dringend eine
risiko-reduktion erfolgen muss dafür
sind Gespräche notwendig zwischen USA
und Russland
weil da auch viele gesprächsfäden die es
im Kalten Krieg eben gab abgerissen sind
um eben
Missverständnisse zu vermeiden dann ist
eine ganz wichtige Forderung die wir
haben das ist eine Erklärung gegen den
Ersteinsatz von Atomwaffen geben muss
von beiden Seiten um einfach das Risiko
noch mal weiter zu verringern
viele Menschen im Land sind ähnlich
verunsichert und teilen den Wunsch nach
Verhandlungen regelmäßig demonstrieren
sie vor dem Bundestag und fordern ein
Ende des Krieges in der Ukraine ohne
wirklich zu wissen wie das gelingen
könnte auch die Parteien im Bundestag
diskutieren darüber wie sehr man sich
Putin in den Weg stellen kann ohne einen
Atomkrieg zu riskieren
die
FDP-Politikerin Marie Agnes Strack
Zimmermann ist Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses sie fordert man
solle sich nicht von Putins Atom
Drohungen beeindrucken lassen die
Ukraine müsse unterstützt werden auch
mit Waffen
ich glaube die nukleare Drohung von
Putin habe besonders die Kollegen und
Kolleginnen im Kanzleramt sehr
beunruhigt dahingehend dass wir ja nach
dem Überfall Russlands auf die Ukraine
24 Februar Wochen Monate lang die
Bundesregierung gewartet hat bis sie
endlich reagiert hat insofern war das
Thema Atom natürlich in manchen
Politiker Kopf dritter Weltkrieg Atom
also es gibt immer so trägerwörter die
bei dem eine oder anderen eben große
Unruhe verursacht hat uns gelernt das
ist ein großer Fehler wir sollten uns
nicht leben lassen doch genau das ist
ein Ziel der russischen Drohungen je
eingeschüchterter der Westen ist desto
freier sei Putin in seinen
Entscheidungen
allein schon die die Drohung mit der
Waffe ist eine Waffe weil die westlichen
offenen Gesellschaften darauf reagieren
das heißt Putin droht damit
und bewirkt damit schon etwas in unseren
offenen Gesellschaften
eben weil putinsdrohung mit der
nuklearen Eskalation wirke beteilige
sich die NATO nicht direkt am Ukraine
Krieg mit ihren Waffenlieferungen tasten
sich die USA und ihre Verbündeten dabei
an die roten Linien Putins heran ohne
genau zu wissen wo sie verlaufen und
erreicht die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine die russische Schmerzgrenze
könnte Putin Befehlen seine taktischen
Atomwaffen für einen Einsatz
vorzubereiten
[Musik]
das wäre ein zusätzliches Element des
politischen Drucks dass die erhöhte
Bereitschaft der russischen Führung zum
Einsatz von Atomwaffen demonstrieren
würde natürlich um den Westen von der
Ernsthaftigkeit der russischen Absichten
zu überzeugen
im Moment weitet Putin den Krieg in der
Ukraine mit konventionellen Waffen aus
doch niemand kann mit Sicherheit sagen
ob er nicht doch zur Bombe greift zwei
Entwicklungen hält der amerikanische
Historiker Wort Wilson dabei für
vorstellbar
eine Möglichkeit ist dass die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte das ganze
Gebiet zurückerobern und es dann zu
einer Friedensregelung kommt das wird
also den Wert von Atomwaffen mindern den
Putin hat all diese nuklearen Drohungen
ausgesprochen und die Ukraine haben sie
ignoriert und den Krieg trotzdem
gewonnen das wäre das gute Ergebnis das
andere Ergebnis ist dass die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte weiter
vorstoßen und Putin so frustriert
gedemütigt und verzweifelt wird dass er
auf dem Schlachtfeld Atomwaffen einsetzt
und dann haben wir wahrscheinlich den
Dritten Weltkrieg
die alte Ordnung der atomaren
Abschreckung gilt nicht mehr
russland hat sich seine eigenen Regeln
gemacht
ein gefährliches Spiel das schnell außer
Kontrolle geraten kann
und ganz offensichtlich weiß momentan
niemand ob und wie man Putin wieder zur
Vernunft bringen kann
[Musik]